삼행시
오늘 교양 필수시간 삼행시의 이해 제1강 시간으로 여러분들과 함께 하려고 하는데
삼행시 어렵다고 생각하시는 분도 많습니다 삼행시도 시기 때문에 이거 내가 할 수 있는 건가라는 생각이 들기도 하고
또 약간 즉흥성과 어떤 순발력을 요구해서 많은 분들이 좀 어려워 하시는데
오늘 정말 초급반 이제 비기너들이 시작할 수 있는 교양 과목 시간 준비를 해봤는데
여러분들과 한번 함께 해보도록 하겠습니다
재밌겠지?
네 일단 간단하게 설명부터 드릴게요 삼행시의 이해
여러분들 문학에 크게 두 가지 정도 있습니다 두괄식이 있고요 미괄식이 있습니다
삼행시도 마찬가지예요 두괄식이 있고요 미괄식이 있습니다 미괄식
두괄식 머리도 짜서서 글의 첫 번째 말에다가 이제 핵심을 넣어놓는 거
미괄식은 반대입니다 마지막에 자기가 하고 싶은 말을 넣는 거예요
마지막에 방점이 찍히는 게 바로 이 미괄식 꼬리밑 짜서서 미괄식인데
삼행시의 99%는
미괄식 되겠습니다 고전 클래식 예시 하나 드려드릴게요
황선홍으로 삼행시를 한다 황으로 시작하는 단어
선으로 시작하는 단어 홍으로 시작하는 단어를 쭉 다 씁니다
여러분들 황으로 시작하는 단어 한번 불러보실까요?
황금발 황금발 황리도 있고요 황리 황리 있고요 황보 황보 있죠
선으로 시작하는 단어죠 선으로 시작하는 단어 여러분 선생님 있겠고요
황빵 선생님 있겠고요 홍으로 시작하는 단어 한번 가볼까요 홍으로 시작하는 단어
홍명보 나올 수 있는데 쭉 써놓습니다
삼행시라는 거는 이 단어들을 선으로 읽는 거예요
근데 뭐라고 했죠 제가 이거 삼행시 두괄식이라고 했으니까 미괄식이라고 했으니까
미괄식이니까 홍으로 시작하는 단어 중에 가장 딱 처음 들었을 때 웃긴 단어
재밌는 단어로 하나 생각을 해 놓고 그 다음에 시작을 하는 겁니다
홍명보가 재밌을 것 같은 느낌이 많이 들어요 황선홍 삼행시라는데 홍명보가 나오니까
홍명보에다 방점을 딱 찍어 놓고 시작을 하는 겁니다
황선홍 삼행시인데 갑자기 홍명보로 꺾기는 재미가 있으려면은 황선홍 선수를 칭찬해 주는 데는
이 내용이 앞에 깔려 있어야 됩니다
황금발 선수들의 우상 홍명보 이렇게 하면은 굉장히 고전 클래식 삼행시가 하나가 완성이 되게 됩니다
간단한 예제를 여러분들께 보여드렸으니까 지금 이제 또 여러분들의 성함으로 여러분들 진짜 여러분들 성함으로 한번
시작해서 즉흥으로 삼행시를 또 완성하는 시간 한번 가져볼게요 여러분들 성함 한번 올려주시겠어요
재밌겠지
네 좀 쭉쭉 올려주시고 계신데
이예나 한번 갈까요 이예나 이예나
처음에 제가 뭐라 그랬어요 미관식이라고 그랬죠 그럼 나부터 찾는 거예요 나
나로 시작하는 재밌는 단어 뭐 있을까요 느낌 올만한 단어 저는 일단 나영석PD 생각나고요
나주곰탕 생각나고요 나루토도 있을 수 있겠죠
여러분들 나로 시작하는 재밌는 단어를 올려주시면 여러분들과 함께 삼행시 만들어 가도록 하겠습니다
나로 시작하는 또 재밌는 단어 뭐 있을까요 여러분들
나주
나주 했는데요 좀 전에
나일론
나일론 나가리도 나오네 나가리 나가리 느낌 오는데 나가리 좋은데요
나야나 나야나도 있는 나는 갈게 많습니다
나무아미타불도 있네요
저는 벌써 지금 한 일곱 개 정도 나왔어요 솔직히 예를 들어서 나무아미타불로 갈 거면 나무아미타불 괜찮은데 그러면
이래가지고 이제서야 고백합니다 예수님 나무아미타불 이렇게 하면 세트 하나 완성되는 거예요 근데 여러분들과 천천히 호흡하기 위해서 가는 겁니다
예를 들어서 나일론으로 간다
뭐 이마트에서 샀는데 오 예술이네요 나일론 100% 뭐 이런 식으로 호흡으로 쭉 가는 겁니다
하지만 여러분과 함께 호흡하기 때문에 하나 골라주세요 어떤 게 좋을까요 나중에 뭐 어떤거로 갈까요
나우나로 하고 싶네요
나우나로 갈까요 음 저는 나야나로 갈 생각이었는데
나야나요
나야나 이는 사실 이라는 글자는 여러분들 삼행시 많이 해보시면 알겠지만
이는 어디에다 붙여도 붙어요 이 이라는 이 그 디스 그 지시대명사가 앞에 붙는 거는 어디에도 붙기 때문에 이는 약간 차체로
얘가 또 방점을
서브 메인입니다 얘가
얘로 시작하는 단어 뭐 있을까요?
예림이
예림이 괜찮은거 나올거 같은데 느낌있죠?
갑니다 그러면 예림이와
나야나를 엮는다
안될거 같은데
최악입니다
요거 지금 채팅창에 이런거 써주셨습니다
이화여대 나온사람
예림이 그게 누구야?
나야나 나야나
이런식으로 원래 예림이 나야나
나머지 제가 완성을 해봤어요
오 여러분들 센스 좋은데요? 이런식으로 하는겁니다
다음에는 가기전에 제가
정말 손쉽게 할 수 있는
편법 하나 알려드릴게요 요거는 요리로 따지면은
미원 다시 따 MSG같은거고
정말 쉽게 갈 수 있는 지름길입니다
정말 삼행시가 어렵다 하시는 분들
요거 세가지 기억하시면 됩니다
유 지 음
유지음 기억하시면 됩니다
유지음 뭐냐
유명인
지명
음식
요걸로 엮으면 어떻게든 됩니다
제가 하나 보여드릴까요? 여러분들 이름 하나만 주세요
신은규 갈까요? 신은규
어떻게 제가 그냥
어떻게든 완성시키는거만 보여드릴게요
신은규 갑니다
신당동에 은재나 맛있는 규동집
이렇게 가면 그냥
그냥 말은 되요 의미는 없지만 사실 뭐
삼행시에서 의미가 있을수도 있고 없을수도 있는데
신당동 지명들어갔죠 규 음식이름 들어갔죠
은은 또 약간
은재나 이렇게 해가지고
이다교님 가볼까요?
이다교 뭐로 시작하는 단어?
교리김밥 있죠 교리김밥 좋은데 맛있는데요
단어가 맛있습니다 맛있는 단어로 시작하시면은
삼행시 성공하실 확률이 굉장히
높아집니다 교리김밥을 한번 가볼까요?
이렇게 많이 넣어도 되요?
다 넣는다구요? 계란지단을?
교리김밥 이렇게 되면은 레시피도
완성이 되고
말도 되죠 실제로 교리김밥은
어 교촌치킨
교촌치킨으로 갈수도 있습니다 이다교로
다시 한번 가볼게요 교촌치킨
이거 정말 고민되네 다 사랑시킬까?
이런 말 되죠 여러분?
다사랑치킨 또 유명한 브랜드
교촌치킨도 굉장히 또 많은 분들께 최악입니다
재치있는 댓글이 하나 올라왔네요
이번 방송 다망했다
교수님 강탈을 부탁드리도록 하겠구요
밀 최하늘님 성함으로
시작을 한번 해보려고 하는데
늘을 시작하는 단어 예를 들어서 뭐 늘보라던지
그런 몇개 빼고는 없기때문에
없는 단어는 사실 못해요 요거부터 말씀드리면
저는 둥법칙을 여간에선 사용하지 않으려고
노력을 많이 합니다 왜냐면 좀 약간
구질구질하고 좀 없어보이기 때문에
회장님이 정말 죄송합니다 하지만 어쩔 수 없었어요
늘로 시작한 단어는 진짜 없어요
뭐 이런식으로 약간 또 귀엽게 하면은
최악입니다 최애는 하나야
늘상 말했잖아
좋은데?
늘로 시작한 단어는 진짜 없어요
좋은데요?
최하늘 하나뿐인 내 사랑
늘 당신만을 바라보고 있어
좋은데?
없는 단어는 사실 못해요
최진식 하기스는
늘어난다지?
어허
너무 좋은데?
늘로 시작한 단어는 진짜 없어요
여러분들 많이 성장하셨군요 이 짧은 사이에
진짜
뿌듯합니다
근데 여러분들 시간 많았잖아요
나는 이거 하면서 해야되는거
조금 구질구질하고 좀 없어보이기 때문에
여러분들 성함 하나만 더 해볼까요?
여민서 해볼까요?
저는 그냥 진짜 지금으로 할 수 있어요
여주에서도 소문났던데요
민서님 멋있는거
이런식으로 그냥 만들 수 있어요
만들 수 있는데 여러분들과 함께
호흡을 오늘 천천히 가져가기 위해서 이렇게 하는겁니다
음식으로도 갈 수 있죠
최악입니다
선우 시작한 단어 뭐 있을까요?
서쪽하늘
서기포
네? 뭐라고요?
섭섭해
짜증나게 하지 마세요
아까 저희 피디님이
섭섭해 했는데
이렇게 할 수 있겠네요
민머리라니요 섭섭해요
뭐 이렇게 가도 약간
짜증나게 하지 마세요
여기 아무도 없어요? 민트초코 드시는 분
섭섭해
짜증나게 하지 마세요
여보
민서 자요
아 이건 읽으면 안되겠네요
여자친구가 민박집 가재
아 이것도 읽으면 안되겠네
내릴게요 내릴게요
지금 이렇게 간단하게 여러분들 강의를 한번 드려봤는데
이제는 앉아가지고 여러분들 성함으로
진짜 즉흥으로 한번 해볼게요 삼행시를
저 펜 하나만 얻어주실 수 있나요?
어 감사합니다
유기선님 감사합니다
유기선님 감사의 의미로
유기선님 성함으로 삼행시 한번 즉흥으로 한번 해볼까요?
아니요
최재옥
최재옥이라는 이름으로 한번 가볼게요
최재옥이라는 이름으로 삼행시 갑니다
최소 2주 넘게 기다린 것 같아요
제 택배 어디 있는 거예요?
옥천
택배계의 범위다 삼각지대라고 하는
옥천에 있으니까 최재옥님 너무 고민하지 마시구요
고완나님도 아까 있었죠?
고완나
고완나님 성함으로 한번 더 가볼까요?
고거 한번
잠시만 다시 다시
고완나님 성함으로 갈게요
아 그게 그렇게 어렵습니까?
한번만 더 보여주세요 제발요
나훈아콘서트
하여튼 말되죠
왜냐면 나훈아콘서트
다시보기 없음
저도 진짜 풀버전으로 보고싶은데 못보니까
고완나님 이거 있네요 고구마 한박스
나교먹고 나왔다 방구
오 이거 좋은데 귀엽다
천준우님
천준우님 성함으로 한번 가려면은
우에다 방점을 찍어야 되는거 제가 말씀드렸잖아요
우를 시작하는
괜찮은 단어들 생각을 해보고서
다다님께서
천재라더니 존나 재미없네
우얄거야 라고 말씀드렸네요
강태
어 이거도 좋네요
아 이분은 수업을 제대로 드셨네
천재적인 두뇌
준수한 외모
우린 아냐
여러분들 진짜 실력이 대단하죠?
양찬형 한번 해볼까요? 양찬형님
양찬형
이런 것도 이렇게 하면 안 돼요
양아치야
찬밥 더운밥 가릴 때냐
영 분위기 파악 못하네
이런 식으로 하면 안 된다는 겁니다
이런 식으로 하면
내가 양찬형님을 알지도 못하는데
지금 이렇게 좀 찬양해 드리고
좀 이렇게 기분 좋게 해 드려야 되는데
이렇게 가면 안 됩니다
어 이거 좋은데요?
양치하는데 찬물 나와
영
아 이게 영이 약간 아쉬운데
이거 이거 지금 우리 과제로 가죠
우은혜님께서 지금
양치하는데 찬물 나와 영
점점 해주셨는데
이거 우리 한번 완성해 봅시다
양치하는데 찬물 나와까지는 되게 좋거든요
양치하는데 찬물 나와 영
뭐 있을까요 영
현장에서도 아이디어 있으면 쭉쭉 주세요
안 죽고요?
괜찮아?
아니 근데 영어친 데 왜 괜찮은 거야?
최악입니다
아 이거다
이거로 갑니다 세플님 걸로 갑니다
양치하는데 찬물 나와 영동보일러 써야지
이걸로 갑니다
영동 아닌가?
경동이죠
세플 강퇴
아 깜빡 속았잖아요
근데 영동보일러 없어?
검색 한번 해봐
영동보일러 있을 거 같은데 왠지
있지?
그래 미안합니다
세플님 오늘 굉장히 또 높은 점수 드리도록 하겠고요
아 없어요?
아 세플님 뭐예요
근데 대리점도 인정해야 되는 거 아니야?
한 번 더 해볼까요?
서은선님
이름이 사실 저는 이미 나오긴 나왔어요
이런 거 하려고 그랬어요
서러워도 울지 마세요 은퇴에도 최고인 선동열
뭐 이런 식으로 하려고 그랬는데
이게 서가 약간 좀 애매해가지고 부끄럽습니다
이상민님께서도 서울의 자랑 은평구의 미래 선동열님으로 이렇게 하셨는데
사실 선동열님이 은평구 출신이신지 지금 미지수거든요
근데 이렇게 하신 거는 이거는 굉장히 제가 칭찬드리는 포인트
선에서 시작하신 거 선동열로 하신 거
선동열이 사실 굉장히 또 매력적인 시어거든요
지금 투머로우 P님께서
스장 남천동 살지 은 선때 임마
최악입니다
은도 말이 안 되고
신당동에 은재나 맛있는 규동집
이렇게 하면 그냥 말은 돼요
딱 단어가 그리고 이 문장이 여러분들
딱딱 끊겨야 돼요
그 한 줄의 시어에서 딱딱땅 끊겨야 되는데
아마 서은선하고 서장? 서장하면 그 서장 재밌는 명대사 있는데?
어? 서장 남천동 살지?
어? 은이 없는데?
은! 이거 딱 놓고 그러면
선! 선은 원래 그런 대사가 없었지만
선때로 하면 이게 말이 맥락상 들지 않을까요?
선때 임마! 하면 재밌게
키키키키 하고서 아마 써주셨을 텐데
아 좀 그렇네요
어 이런 거 좋네요
서민들의 은인 선짓국
아 좋습니다
어허
어 이거 좋은데?
김민지님 서에서 보자 은팔찌는 선물이야
어?
어 이거 좋은데? 김민지님 서에서 보자 은팔찌는 선물이야
아 잠만 근데
이건 서은선님한테 저희가 선물해드리는
삼행시인데
아 이거 근데
서은선님께는 죄송하지만
이거 삼행시 딱 지으신 걸로
어우 굉장히 김민지님 센스 너무 좋으셨어요
서에서 보자 은팔찌는 선물이야
아 이거 맥락만 딱 맞으면은
어 너무 좋은데요?
다음 이름 가도록 하겠습니다 다음 이름
여러분들 이런 시간 별로 없습니다
얼마나 영광입니까
예 여러분들 성함으로 진짜
이런 말씀 그냥 저
편하게 할게요 제가 사실
제 채널이고 제 개인 방송이니까 편하게 말씀드리겠습니다
유병재가
삼행시를
전 세계에서 제일 잘합니다
왜냐면 보세요
한국에선 솔직히 저 삼행시 겨를 사람 그렇게 많지 않아요
근데 전 세계에서 한국밖에 삼행시를 안 해요
일단은 나는 우주에서 제일 잘하는 사람일 수도 있다
이거 정말 고민되네
고거 한 번
아 잠시만요 잠시만요 잠시만요 잠시만요
요 이런 유병재 삼행시에 다닌
삼달 유병재가 지금 여러분들 성함으로 함께 이렇게 또
삼행시
김한결님 갈까요 김한결님
저 아까 세풀님이 영동보일러 했던 분이지 세풀님
세풀님이 좀 다 여줬는데
김한결 어디 갔어
한결이 없어요
결석 체크
너무 귀엽지 않아요?
너무 귀엽죠
어 세풀님 되게 귀여워지네요
네 강석장님께서 유병재 선생님
이번 수능 끝나고 수업 들러 오겠습니다
강석장님 약속 꼭 지켜주시고요
수능 잘 보시고 또 저희 수업 들러 가시기 바랍니다
수능은 능이 버섯밖에 없어서
최악입니다
수능으로 한 번 여러분들의 응원해 드릴 수 있는
이행시 한 번 지어 보도록 하겠습니다
이런 거 한 번 가볼까요
수없이 날 괴롭혔었던 스트레스들
능지처참
이런 식으로 가도 될 것 같죠
수험 출제자가 낸 함정들
능구렁이처럼 잘 빠져나가세요
뭐 이런 식으로 해도 또 말이 되겠고요
리즈님 수영은 능숙하게
지금 그런 분위기가 아니고 저희가
이제 의미 있게 여러분들 이제 응원해 드리기 위해서
수없이 마려운 능각
지금 그 분위기 아니라고 말씀을 드렸는데
김예은님께서 수요일에 능력 보여주자 라고 말씀하셨는데
수능 목요일이거든요
12월 3일이지만 목요일인데
이것도 귀엽다
안유님께서 수능 잘 보라
수능
귀엽네요 귀엽네요
재밌겠지?
자 오늘 교양 필수 과목
삼행시의 이해 제1강 한 번 함께 해봤는데
과제 한 번 내드리도록 하겠습니다
여러분들 다음 시간까지 과제입니다
과제 초겨울 삼행시 12월
말장난 김장철 은갈치 한근옥
이 일곱 가지 단어를 가지고
뭐 하나만 보내주셔도 좋고요
저에게 인스타 DM으로 과제 제출해 주시기 바랍니다
다음 수업 시간 때 과제 확인하고 수업도 진행하도록 하겠습니다
늦은 시간까지 시청해주신 여러분들
고마워요
지금 뭐 벌써 김경담 님께서
삼행시 하기 싫은데 행으로 시작하는 게 뭐가 있지?
씨발 안 해